what is that what is this that's Korean
spicy chicken noodles a lot of people do
this online as a the chicken noodle
spicy chicken no challenge what's the
challenge it's super hot it's very spicy
you made it cut yeah this is the bag of
ramen that Qin brought last week Oh guys
no disrespect you know I love your cat
if I ate that I would [ __ ] my pants
I can handle spicy though right yeah of
course is it does need to be warmed up
but he's good
no you're good all right cool take that
to the dome right now be let's see
straight to the dome he's just one hole
in yeah suck it in suck it in then wash
it down whiskey hold on hey you know you
should do is chew into the mic that's
fun sounds good oh you like it
Papa like pop pop just pop a lover know
why is just so hot cat what's in it the
seasoning this is stuff you love Qin I
love it but it's so hard to get through
for me but a lot yeah cuz yeah
it's tough for me try some ring I'm just
not in the space to try it
oh yeah Nick Dean I've had candy I've
had Brian love that this is my second
americano
I've had whiskey very nice I had chicken
tortilla soup
I'll today what happens at the hot sauce
daddy doesn't get wait daddy wipe your
lips when daddy your lips are red daddy
I'm pop-up my mouth is on fire is it
that hot sure my mouth is on fire and
but you'd never know it with me well
okay just does get into that though ya
know we're drinking the 17 year old
whiskey bubble how taste something at
night is it Robbie what at night I get
lonely I get a little anxious and I
start drinking yeah and I eat Sarge
activities and they eat cookies are you
ice cream sandwiches I just said I would
never do does the quarantine yeah let's
do some current events
won't cheat some more noodles they were
very hot I want to take for it to go
away yeah I can
the whole thing no problem oh yeah this
is no problem yeah do it man and I'm
gonna have a raspberry this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
good what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]